d'un côté on a une femme qui est
présidente de région qui met en place
tout un tas de mesures qui sont d'une
très grande efficacité et de l'autre on
a des gens qui sont en apesanteur soit
qu'ils sont pas candidats et qui dépense
l'argent des français avec la c max et
lakro et puis vous avez les autres qui
sont des commentateurs monsieur zemmour
qui a jamais dirigé mais me direz que je
crois qu'il n'a même jamais été chef
d'une rédaction et il nous explique
qu'il va diriger la france fait tout ça
est quand même très très foot absurde
les pros nous sommes des gens sérieux et
d'expérience nous sommes l'antithèse de
soyez fiers d'être des amateurs des
manuels macron à ses troupes il ya
quelques années soyez fiers d'être des
amateurs savent c'est quoi la le sens
profond de cette affaire ça signifie que
l'activité politique serait la seule
activité humaine ou l'inexpérience
serait gage d'efficacité goût et vous
avez dans votre vie professionnelle vous
êtes meilleur aujourd'hui que vous
n'étiez à 10 20 30 ans en tout cas c'est
mon cas et bien emmanuel macron essaye
de vous vendre l'idée que moi vous êtes
bon plus vous êtes amateur puis vous
êtes amateur meilleur vous à c'est une
forme de populisme c'est du populisme
évidemment je vous donne un conseil si
vous faite opérer demain par un
chirurgien
prenez pas d'amateurs prenez quelqu'un
qui à quelques heures de route quand je
monte dans un avion j'aime bien que le
gars est un peu voulait plutôt que ce
soit novateur
l'expérience politique c'est fondamental
parce qu'on sait on sait la difficulté
des choses la complexité de celle ci on
sait que ce n'est pas en un claquement
de doigts qu'on va vous gouvernez
réformer la france et ce à une valérie
pécresse on aurait nettement sur le jeu
est la seule à avoir des propositions
qui sont très concrets est sûre ça pose
un problème démocratique que le
président se présentent pas ou alors les
excuses les explications sur l'ukraine
épidémie ce je pense oui je pense que ça
pose un problème parce qu'on y fait
campagne avec des moyens de l'état très
clairement
aucun élu local aucun maire qu'un
président de conseil départemental ou
régional n'aurait le droit de faire ce
qu'il fait c'est à dire de faire de
dépenses nouvelles à quelques semaines
d'une élection ça c'est interdit par la
loi électorale or lui le fait d'une main
r totalement décomplexé il va même
inaugurait ce commissariat dont le
permis de construire délivré rnis enfin
moi hier on est dans de
l'hypercommunication failli tout le
monde le sait tout le monde le voit
c'est de la com ce n'est pas correct
d'ailleurs il a dit qu'il ne pouvait pas
être candidat tant que la crise
sanitaire et la crise diplomatique ne
serait pas réglée il a fait cette
déclaration
si je le suis il sera jamais candidat
avant plusieurs mois